you can comment and you know how can
respond
uh to what their visa visa doing
well i'll make an exception and say that
it was a private opinion a private
initiative
by one of the parliamentaries um this
and we are determined to keep continuing
um our relations with the european union
on the basis of parity and equality
on mutual respect and on the principles
of the international law and that's the
basis we stand on
and it's never changed and we fully
understand that there
are some you know rhythm phobic lobbying
going on
in european union and
unfortunately there is some pressure
from the united states too
but we also understand that there is
sincere interest
of other parties within the european
union
as well as citizens of the european
union to have
a normal bilateral relations with the
eu and russia and for bilateral
relations
um with individual member states of the
eu
and russia and that's the track we are
going to building the relations
on and there has been a forum
organized by the russian uh council
on uh affairs it was opened by
foreign minister lavrov and his
portuguese counterpart
um and um they discussed the crisis of
trust as a global problem in the entire
world
and um sergio lavrov told
about that the eu seems to be blocking a
lot of initiatives lately
and unfortunately many of them have been
just
stopped to and
a lot of initiatives were sort of tied
to this sort of so-called european
ukrainian problem
but why coming back to another
interesting
issue it's probably not right for the
brussels
to tie everything in
russian eu relations with ukraine we
need
to address the problem rather than
create the problem
we need to continue fulfilling our
agreements so ins
instead of uh solving the problem based
on the minsk agreements
uh eu seems to be broad lobbying
a different approach also
because there is also pressure from the
united states but this is
a vicious logic this is a vicious circle
it's not
going to produce a solution that would
work
and that's exactly the message we're
trying to send
to our eu counterparts and that
we are committed to cooperating based
on the principles of equality
but we can also give a response if
necessary
well that's a classic uh you know
when we another
line here from the brussels lately
um they use it not only in regards to
russia but to other countries as well
so they raise issues with other
countries and now
we can only say that the european union
has
the same problems so they probably
should
rather pay their attention to their own
problems on
in that area than the problems of the
same kind in other countries
or they can take a look at how
police in the u eu is um
cracking down on protests in the
european union
and they can look at the people who have
been persecuted
like uh julian assange what about other
reporters and journalists uh they are
being
exiled from many countries uh like uh
art
journalists have been exiled or
pressured out of
air uh in latvia and lipval for example
these are the problems of the european
union
well just now the entire world
saw another
wave of violence um
an armed conflict uh it's a
very old problem this
middle east settlement problem and
unfortunately
it has become a more acute problem
than just settlement it's a stand-up
and russia has been very actively
involved in trying to normalize the
situation
we've been contacting uh the
intermediaries
and we certainly were the country
that uh boosted the activity of the
quartet
as for the meeting you're referring to
uh
it's two meetings there are two
different initiatives here
uh one initiative is to have a meeting
in moscow
uh between the leaders of israel and
palestine
this was initiated by russia quite a
while ago
and it still is open and the other
initiative
is the initiative for the quartet
we think it would have a lot and
we're working on it right now as for the
representatives of the quartet
they are in contact all the time with us
uh we have new technologies to keep in
contact remotely all the time
foreign
well there's a funny expression
well these are sort of baby steps you're
right
well you know two superpowers
um
that have a great history including the
recent history i have lots of
obligations uh in the u.n security
council
i think we need to start making more
serious steps rather than
baby steps
well that's just a comment but you're
right
i did not really
have the mandate to comment on this kind
of summit
that i would have my colleagues in
kremlin comment on that
but in general uh the relations
of the united states has been always
sincere
and we've been talking uh with our
counterparts in the united
states that we want to build our
relations on the principles
of the equality and for the benefit of
our peoples and
certainly our starting point is that
there are issues we agree on and the
issues we disagree on and that's normal
we are different countries and each
country has its own history
and we have some common ground but also
we have
differences on a number of issues on
both international agenda
and in the area of bilateral relations
but that does not mean
that we need to be confronting each
other
all the time blocking
you know the ways to find solutions to
the
issues and we've been saying about that
openly for quite a while we witnessed
uh russia american relations is
degrading
recently there have been some
quite perverted ways of the united
states
to try and pressure russia there have
been some real estate
taken away from russia on the american
soil
but i would like to remind that the um
this is russian property and that's a
direct violation of the vienna
convention it was just taken away from
us
and that breaks uh the international
convention
and in the united states irm and again
have been coming up
with uh various stories of solidarity
and so on and it having
uh diplomatic stuff exiled from many
other countries
nato countries including so there have
been
lots of steps made that have led us
to making a decision that we need to
produce a list of
unfriendly nations and on the united
nations were the first to be included on
the
the united states were the first nation
to be included on that list
well i would say that
um russian foreign minister's
cooperation with his american
counterparts as constructive
that's how it is and that's what the
last meeting was like
uh we are working very constructively
and i think
everyone can acknowledge the same we
started with
outlining our positions and that was
quite constructed
uh each of the counterparts just
presented their position
and confirmed their readiness to
continue
working and it will be a long process
understandably
so i believe it was a good experience
well as i already stand there is a
mandate i cannot speak for the entire
country for the entire state
well uh that's a great question
what is the main reason for a country
for a nation to be included on such a
list
well there are two countries on the list
right now
the czech republic and the united states
well the answer to your question is
unfriendly actions
whenever a nation undertakes a number of
unfriendly actions not as a mistake not
as an
accident but as a way of
tackling a situation uh when we're
talking about
permanently unfriendly actions that
gives us the reason and the basis for
reacting this way speaking of the
recent developments and the recent wave
of
sanctions against russia
this gives us ground to believe it's a
system which isn't it which
is
well the main the key thing
we are for um
building relations based on the
principle of equality maybe it's
old-fashioned
maybe people are expecting something
else from us
something new and how we would like to
build our relations with other nations
but i think it's a good tradition
that we need to maintain mutual respect
equality parity
uh after these basis we can do
other things we can become uh allies we
can build a special relation
uh there can be a cooling down of
relations um
you know it all can go down different
tracks but the basis should be the same
as i mentioned
that if that is observed
then domination will ever be included on
that list
but i would like to ask a question to
those
countries why would they be pursuing
such an
entire russia policy for so many years
so that it would uh inhibitively make
russia
to react in such ways as expel diplomats
and why what did they get
what what is their benefit but there is
no benefit
uh that's all i can say i believe that
the collective
losses of the west from the measures
they were
trying to use against russia
it just hit back on themselves
you